This microwave listens to popcorn popping
to perfectly cook popcorn every time.
And the Iowa Storm Chasing Network recently
unveiled a 10,000 pound armored van specifically
designed to get closer than ever to tornados.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
The Sulon Cortex Headset hopes to merge the
real world with virtual reality.
The idea is to overlay a virtual environment
on your physical surroundings.
It works using a head position tracker and
a game controller tracker along with a sensor
package that maps the world around you.
Basically turning the real world into a video
game.
Developer kits are available for pre-order
right now.
Neuroscape Lab created a real-time 3D visualization
of the human brain.
The colors represent source power and connectivity
and the estimated information transfer can
be seen as pulses of light moving along the
fiber tracts connecting the regions of the
brain.
And you can even fly through the brain activity
of someone wearing an EEG cap using a gamepad.
Space Generator is a room concept that allows
you to create any type of room you can imagine.
Winner of the 2013 Red Dot concept award - the
pre-programmed module cells can be raised
or lowered to transform the once flat platform
into any number of 3D arrangements - creating
the space for a fashion show, a theater or
any kind of or a game installation like a
maze.
Facebook's facial recognition technology is
nearly as accurate at recognizing faces as
you are.
Their research project titled DeepFace can
look at two photos and regardless of the angle
or lighting tell with 97.25% accuracy whether
they contain the same face - something humans
can do at 97.53%.
This new technology is not currently used
on the Facebook website but ostensibly could
eventually be used to link every photo of
you online to your Facebook account.
Audi's traffic light recognition system counts
down the time remaining until a red light
turns green.
It works by reading the automated signals
from the city's central traffic computer and
sending that data to the driver - it will
also let you know if you can make it through
a green light or if you should start braking.
But there's no current date for when this
will be available in the U.S.
A new study shows that forgetting is actually
an active process - specifically that a protein
called Musashi is necessary for memory-loss
- hopefully this research can someday lead
to treatments for Alzheimer's disease.
This 360 degree Milky Way panorama from NASA
features two and a half million snapshots
taken over a decade and stitched together
for the first time.
Find the link below to explore this monumental
space image.
Tidy Dog hopes to train your dog to put away
its toys.
It uses sensors to detect the weight of a
toy when the dog puts it back in the bin - and
then dispenses a treat.
Rewarding your pooch for cleaning up.
Finally, Firefight Films created Bigger Than
Life - Ice Caves - which is the first documented
drone flight through ice caves.
I'm gonna leave you with a robot that learns
by imitating a human and then performs that
task better than the human - and as always
thanks for watching.